ó ó olhe que não
muito bom dia bom dia a todos e obrigada
obrigada pra vocês escolheram escolheram
os para que os assentados para poderem
assistir a esta é ter é que está aqui
disse
leiria pode escolher os assentados eu
não eu estou é viver a minha condição de
primeiro depoimento sentada
desde o dia em que faz xixi desde 1983
não é tarde eu quero que vocês encaram
em sto
as rodas estas e muitas outras
esta história de viver um sobre rodas
sejam elas quais forem concessões porque
sim que desde o primeiro dia da minha
vida é seguir ao choro do a vida estou
aqui quer é viver sobre rodas uma vez
aliás é eu começo a achar que a história
do medo eu chamar acho que a gente
sempre feita dia será alterada para
sorrir gênese prefeita nas imperfeições
de vida
sim de facto é este meu sorriso doce da
pessoa que mais me ensinou a sorrir ao
longo da vida
neste momento o espaço no céu e eu tento
e levar todos os dias é que ela me
ensinou é que o que o meu pai também me
ensinou que está aqui nesta porta é é
sorrir para ajuda e ia fazer do gado que
é o sorriso no fundo a minha maior
herança no fundo tá aí o poucas coisas
para partilhar com vocês dado o tempo
que nunca é disposto e também é que
podia contar os
ao longo destes 12 minutos
é sobre o que é preciso estudar e viver
sobre rodas
vocês é de certeza que quando o vai
andar e falar que estava em uma cadeira
de rodas seja isso é uma condição
permanente essa gente por causa de um
acidente ou ainda é desde a adolescência
como é o meu caso
as pessoas pensam que essa história de
diversão de rosas e uma tragédia o drama
não é filha de rosa está aí muitas
vantagens
eu posso andar calçados e não tropece no
fundo a andar sobre rosas e pura e
simplesmente uma nova visão da vida e eu
escolhi viver esta vida sobre rodas é
diferente o que é diferente não é
necessariamente mau
ela seja sempre feita é uma doença que
se caracteriza por falta de cálcio nos
ossos e uma grande percentagem de
fraturas desde a emergência é ter a
idade adulta
posso dizer que já a partir dos meus
sócios colégio 80 e 90 vezes em todos os
museus é em queda fraturou o pé e eu
lembro é de aprender é verdade é sorrir
pra dor é uma escolha é pena porque eu
decidi viver é só isso
ainda com dores e sofrimentos
o sofrimento é uma opção enquanto a dor
é aquela cruzeiro pode ter não é nós
cabe nos a nós fazer é que o tem que ser
fretes para conseguirmos lidar com ela
posso dar um dos muitos exemplos como é
que eu consigo fato
viver a vida é assim é fácil basta olhar
muitas pessoas é tomar banho e que de
facto são uma benção agigantam minha
vida os meus amigos e minha família e as
pessoas com quem trabalho as pessoas que
eu quero vencer ou não de vida
questões que eu tenho tido privilégio de
aprender e de se ver mais o que é isto
de andar num sobre rodas e alguns
vizinhos coisas mais caras mas ao mesmo
tempo fazer sentir completamente
integrada nesta viagem que a vida sobre
rodas coisas colo da minha mãe por
exemplo comprou os sapatos de luxo
passado dois ou três dias com a forma
mais natural possível e ela não estava
em casa disse então filha paris fazendo
a vontade de virar fim com essa
naturalidade
então essa descontração é de fato algo
que está ao alcance de qualquer um de
nós
não é preciso ler muitos livros citar
frase da autoria de obras por exemplo
está disponível
eu estou disponível
a história é não fechar é não sempre
conceito 11min própria e isso é ter a
vela de coragem pisar sobre rodas um
palco e de tv que vocês são muito sair
apesar de não estar a ver nada tá escuro
e é perfeito
eu saí eu acredito que de fato nós não
viemos a vida é a minha missão em junho
queda ele é seja cada vez mais clara
mais coberta por todo o trajeto fato de
que não foi um acidente não foi um
acidente de percurso só olha é pane ao é
pensada é chamada desde a minha situação
e de fato era uma indignidade para com
as pessoas então escolheram tá é com é
que eu tinha créditos que estejam todas
as coisas e kuki com propósito era fato
em admirar seu passado havia triste e
não querer sorrir por fax e foi aprovado
há mesmo muito mais gentis pior porque
eu não é que eu tenha que olhar para as
desgraças dos outros
um sentido de
é só cair afinal eu sou uma das 80 mas
acima de tudo aprender e todos os dias
fazer por crescer mais grata
dentre o time é nós habituados a fechar
o estúdio optou só o proprietário evento
tá vendo
tá tá tá calor tá frio lá esperamos
muito pouco para agradecer porque não
entendem que eu percebi que se eu
agradeço demais a minha vida é seria o
sorriso ainda mais natural sem qualquer
sem qualquer pudor de que o que o meu
corpo as minhas limitações físicas que
eu acredito cada vez mais que não
determina os meus limites
mas esse majestoso é encarar you tudo é
que o que acontece quando uma grávida
é óbvio que eu quero um cartão as coisas
e então gente risos eu tenho um faço a
minha parte para conquistar aquilo que
tinha de vídeo acima de todas
eu acredito piamente que é que o que eu
posso ser
nas minhas rosas não não estava da ásia
é qualquer limite porque a força de
vontade ea cabeça comandou muito mais do
que os olhos cristal que eu acho que já
devia ser patrocinada pela swarovski
não percebo porque é que se não
acontecer eu era e que uma perca de
ontem acredite que os meus olhos são de
cristal estão a ficar cristalizados
porque basicamente o pessoal da terex
resolveu é ovário na teoria prática e
que mesmo receber tanto flaviene que nas
rodas surrey mesmo sobre rodas então
varão e se vire
o pessoal iria retiro numa violenta que
eu pensar de fato que estava a viver a
vida que eu pensava que tem vivido as
aventuras todas dadas na mina na altura
da faculdade é na história tão precisos
chegar à tv que se eu iria para viver
assim um agente de todo o terreno
ontem à noite que de fato fez com que o
medo inicial conseguisse ser substituído
por uma certeza
é gratidão imensa novamente estar
rodeada de pessoas que querem incluir me
que acreditam em mim e que olham para as
rosas como uma extensão de mim e apenas
mais um endereço agora e quando estamos
a acabar com as querem excluir por favor
todos p - o hospital de cadeira de rodas
aos limites só chover
não vejo acreditar agora sim muito vai e
vão se abrir com uma coisa vocês acham
mesmo que estava numa ter apps ia perder
a oportunidade de fazer omelete self
então você rir
i
você tenta diva maria self cena eu
queria que você acha que desempenha
quero poder dizer que o game aplaudido
de pé é serio é que eu quero
outras vezes aqui vocês devem definir
este mês 15 uma certeza a certeza de que
se o rio subir a via com rosas rosas com
ou sem cadeira em ratos e salvar a terra
se qualquer um de nós
e aquilo que nos diferencia os outros
não é sermos corvos marinhos baixos com
acento eficiência altos é conca deu um
claro que no escuro um tonel cpu e
capacidade de sorrir sorrir para os
problemas sorrir para as galerias subir
para o uso e prazer é pelo fundo é o
nosso maior presente não esqueçam que
isso é gratuito e está de fato a tese de
que qualquer um a brigada por terem
escolhido
agora sim está de pé na via
ó ó